hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing auras a
group of elite and highly trained
witches and wizards that work the
department of magical law enforcement
inside the ministry of magic or if
you're in the US for the magical
Congress of the United States of America
comparable to say the Secret Service and
muggle World auras are responsible for
investigating and handling any and all
crimes pertaining to dark Wizards and
dark magic auras of The Wizarding
world's best defense against the
practitioners of the dark arts were
well-versed in offensive magic because
our very lives depend on it it takes
courage wit and guile not many have the
stomach for it do you auras play a
crucial role in maintaining peace and
combating dark Forces in The Wizarding
World serving as an essential pillar of
magical law enforcement they stand as a
symbol of Courage skill and unwavering
dedication the origins of auras traced
back to the tumultuous period of the
18th century when the Wizarding World
faced numerous threats and internal
conflicts this era marked by dark wizard
Supremacy and depression laid the
foundation for the formation of the aura
profession as Wizards and witches became
increasingly concerned about the misuse
of magic an urgent need arose for
skilled individuals who could Safeguard
the magical community and bring Justice
to wrongdoers from quelling Goblin
rebellions to investigating the illegal
trade of magical creatures the auras are
the closest thing to a standing army
that the ministry would ever mobilize
but for a long time the duties of an
aura the apprehension of dark Wizards
and other criminals was just grouped
into the role of other Ministry
officials that meant other members of
the official Wizarding government
especially those within the department
of magical law enforcement fulfilled the
day-to-day tasks that auras were would
eventually do but thanks to the work of
Eldritch diggery the minister for magic
at the time the jobs of wizards and
witches at the ministry of magic
eventually became more specialized and
instead of bullying your average office
worker into enforcing magical laws
diggery created the aura office
following his launch of the first ever
Aura recruitment program and ever since
that fateful day in the early 18th
century the auras have gone on to become
one of the most feared and beloved
aspects of the ministry of magic today
several centuries later we're going to
be honoring the auras of The Wizarding
World by taking a look at each one by
name and recognizing their contribution
to the magical Community as a whole
taking things a step further I'm also
going to be ranking them by their
perceived magical ability this list will
include auras working for the ministry
of magic in the UK as well as U.S auras
working for the magical Congress for the
United States of America it will also
include names from all Wizarding World
material for some of these names I could
write a book full of information but for
others I really had to scrape the barrel
so bear with me there's a fair bit of
ground to cover here so let's dive in
venusia quickly was a competent and
likable British witch that served as
Minister for Magic from 1903 to 1912.
however prior to her service as Minister
venusia worked in the aura Department
tragically venusia died at a relatively
young age from a mandrake-related
gardening accident ESOP Sharp's partner
an unnamed wizard who we know very
little about was as you may have guessed
the crime fighting partner of British
wizard ESOP sharp this wizard was killed
when he and his stop tracked a suspect
to a harbor in Scarborough where they
were ambushed Mordecai Berry cloth was a
British wizard employed by the ministry
of magic under then department head
Harry Potter Berry cloth was described
as being Charisma impaired suggesting
that he was a rather dull individual
however he was quite knowledgeable in
terms of the art of spellcasting
Achilles Toliver was an American wizard
who worked for the magical Congress of
the United States of America in the
1920s Toliver worked alongside
porpentina Goldstein whom he briefly
dated very little is known about Toliver
or his abilities
brownfoot is a relatively minor
character in Harry Potter law who was
part of the squad of Aura stationed in
hogsmeade proudfoot along with a few
others were placed there in order to
help heighten security at Hogwarts
during the 1996 to 1997 school year
Savage was part of the same Entourage
stationed in hogsmeade to protect
Hogwarts it can be safely assumed that
due to the importance of their mission
all of the Wizards stationed in
hogsmeade had an extensive arsenal of
offensive and defensive spells as well
as a considerable amount of experience
dealing with dark Wizards John dulish
was a British Aura working for the
ministry that could often be seen by the
side of Cornelius fudge he's primarily
known for his persistent attempts to
take care of Dumbledore under the orders
of the ministry of magic despite his
dogged determination dawlish is often
outsmarted and overpowered by Dumbledore
and other skilled Wizards some feel that
his repeated failures highlight his lack
of exceptional skill and strategic
thinking as an aura however dawlish has
been described by Dumbledore himself as
an excellent Aura I'm of the impression
that he was just given particularly
difficult assignments after all
Dumbledore is the most powerful wizard
of all time Neville Longbottom a
Gryffindor student at Hogwarts Grew From
an initially timid and clumsy young boy
into a courageous and formidable wizard
undergoing a significant amount of
character development throughout the
series Neville is known for his
Proficiency in herbology and his ability
to stand up against dark Wizards
exemplified by his role in the Battle of
Hogwarts after graduating from Hogwarts
and in impressive display at the Battle
of Hogwarts Neville pursues a career as
an aura in addition to becoming an aura
Neville also follows his Dreams by
becoming a professor of herbology at
Hogwarts Ron Weasley one of Harry's
closest friends and member of the
Weasley Clan joins the aura department
at the ministry of magic after the
second Wizarding War although Ron
occasionally struggles with
self-confidence he possesses a strategic
mind and showcases bravery during
crucial moments Ron's skill set includes
Proficiency in strategic planning as
well as his Proficiency in Wizard chess
which indicates his ability to think
ahead and make calculated decisions
Under Pressure his unwavering commitment
to doing what is right and his ability
to remain cool Under Pressure make him
an effective Aura after many years as an
aura Ron eventually leaves his post to
join his brother George in operating
Weasley's Wizarding wheezers Williamson
was an aura only briefly in the Harry
Potter series not much is known about
his background or specific
accomplishment as an aura he was
described as wearing Scarlet Red robes
and sporting a long ponytail when Harry
Potter first met him notably he was the
first Aura to see Lord Voldemort just
before he fled the ministry of magic in
1996 after the battle of the Department
of mysteries following this encounter he
was sent along with dawlish to go and
deal with the captured Death Eaters to
me the importance of the task to which
he was entrusted suggests that he was
quite a talented wizard Serana Wilkinson
was an aura who served the magical
Congress of the United States of America
A Gifted spellcaster she notably
provided spell casting tips to members
of the statute of secrecy task force in
order to help them better utilize the
weakening hex in combat an international
visit from the American Aura Serana
Wilkinson leaves you with some very
useful tips increasing the amount of
damage done with a successful critical
cast Alice and Frank Longbottom were
auras and members of the original Order
of the Phoenix they were also the mom
and dad of Neville Longbottom as auras
both Alice and Frank were highly
accomplished and highly respected known
for their bravery and skill in combat as
well as their proficient use of
defensive magic unfortunately after
their capture and torture by Death
Eaters Alice and Frank were left
permanently incapacitated their tragic
end serves as a reminder of the dangers
and sacrifices that auras face in the
line of duty the original 12 were a
group of 12 Wizard volunteers from the
United States who trained as auras to
serve the magical Congress of the United
States of America
in the late 17th century things were
tough for Magical people in what would
later become the United States it was a
particularly hostile environment
scourers nefarious bounty hunters and
Crooks roamed the continent preying on
their fellow magical beings for personal
gain on top of that the area was timing
with the Wizarding criminals who had
fled to America from Europe hoping to
stay clear of authorities because the
region had no established form of law
enforcement it made it an easy place to
escape to but then came the Salem Witch
Trials which tipped the scales at this
stage The Wizarding community in America
banded together and established the
magical Congress of the United States of
America in 1693 allowing them to create
their own system of government and order
the first wizard elected president for
makusa Josiah Jackson made recruiting
and training auras his top priority
the first few volunteers all 12 of them
faced immense risks and challenges but
showed impressive bravery as a result
they and their descendants earned the
enduring respect of North America's
magical Community though only two of the
original 12 auras lived well into old
age their legacy lives on these 12 auras
were theodad Fontaine Wilhelm Fisher
gandolfus Graves Robert grimsditch Mary
jauncey Carlos Lopez Mungo McDuff Cormac
O'Brien Abraham Potter Matilda Roche
Helmut Weiss and charity Wilkinson today
only two of these original 12 remain
charity Wilkinson and theodad Fontaine
however the legacy of all 12 of these
Brave auras will stand the test of time
there isn't much information available
on each Aura individually so in terms of
Power Rankings I'm going to have to put
them all together that said with all of
the adversity these 12 Wizards faced I
think it's safe to say that they were
quite a talented group there's also one
name in the group that particularly
stands out one Abraham Potter it's worth
noting that Abraham was born into the
American branch of the Potter family
which also originated from ignotis
pavril this makes Abraham a relative of
Harry ESOP sharp was a British wizard
who worked as an aura for the ministry
of magic he later served as the potions
Master for Hogwarts School after
graduating from Hogwarts himself ESOP
quickly set his sight on the aura office
and began working for them straight away
as his career progressed ESOP and his
partner who I mentioned earlier
valiantly pursued their duties
fearlessly undertaking dangerous
assignments in the name of protecting
The Wizarding World however fate had a
cruel twist in store during one Mission
tragedy struck as they were ambushed
resulting in a grievous injury for ESOP
and the heartbreaking loss of his
partner the aftermath of this
devastating incident cast a shadow on
esop's future prospects as it became
clear that desk duties and endless
paperwork awaited him realizing the
Restriction this would impose on his
adventurous Spirit ESOP made a
life-altering decision he chose to bid
farewell to the ore office and turned
his attention toward imparting his
wisdom to the budding witches and
wizards of the Next Generation right at
his beloved alma mater sharp was
particularly gifted in charms potions
and dueling nymphadora Tonks also known
as Tonks was a half-bud witch and loyal
member of the Order of the Phoenix as an
aura Tonks possessed a full arsenal of
impressive skills necessary for the role
one of her most notable abilities was
being a metamorph Magus allowing her to
change her appearance at will this
Talent made her a valuable asset in
undercover operations and Gathering
crucial information while remaining and
detected donks also showcased expertise
in defense against the dark arts known
for her Proficiency in a multitude of
defensive Bells throughout her career
Tonks demonstrated bravery courage and a
willingness to take risks earning her
the admiration and respect of her
colleagues despite her occasional
clumsiness she didn't let it hinder her
Effectiveness as an aura and remained
determined in her duties Cass carniris
was an American witch and the captain of
auras for the magical Congress of the
United States of America in the 2020s
unfortunately there isn't much available
information out there on Cass however we
do know that she was in charge of
training other auras in the art of
dueling we can also safely assume that
since she came into a position of
authority within makusa that she served
with some sort of Distinction for these
reasons I've decided to place her higher
on the list E A lemus was an American
wizard who worked as both the federal
identity commissioner and chief Aura at
the magical Congress of the United
States of America
the former role involved keeping records
for makusa employees and certifying
employee identification as Chief Aura
they were responsible for overseeing the
work of American auras based on the
amount of responsibility on EA lemus's
shoulders it's fair to assume that he
was a fairly accomplished wizard in his
own right MP karnaris was an American
Wizard and captain of auras of the
magical Congress of the United States of
America MP was likely related to Cass
conerus like some of the others on this
list little is known about carnaris
other than the fact that he attained the
rank of Aura Captain for this reason
he's earned a higher position on this
list ml minus was an American wizard who
hit the top of the totem pole and
achieved the highest honor rank of Aura
commissioner within the magical Congress
the United States of America given the
responsibility associated with this role
it's likely that ml minus was an
incredibly accomplished Aura with a
sharp mind and extensive skill skill set
Harry James Potter the chosen one is a
legendary figure in the Wizarding
Community as the Survivor of Lord
Voldemort's deadly curse as an infant
Harry grew up to become a courageous and
resilient wizard he played a pivotal
role in the defeat of the dark lord
during the Battle of Hogwarts eventually
becoming an aura to continue fighting
against dark Forces and ensuring the
safety of the magical world as an aura
Harry displayed a unique skill set that
made him an exceptional member of the
magical law enforcement from his
impressive dueling skills to his
versatile spell casting abilities Harry
possessed the prowess of a formidable
wizard what truly set Harry apart
however was his immense bravery and
unwavering determination he never shied
away from dangerous missions or took the
easy path Harry fearlessly faced the
unknown embracing the responsibility to
protect his fellow witches and wizards
this resilience and courage made him a
respected Aura and a symbol of hope
within the magical Community furthermore
Harry's experiences as the boy who lived
granted him invaluable knowledge about
dark magic and the workings of
Voldemort's followers this Insight
allowed him to understand the mindset
and strategies of those he pursued as an
aura making him a valuable asset in the
fight against dark Forces
during his time as an aura Harry served
with so much distinction that he was
promoted to head of the Department of
magical law enforcement at the ministry
of magic a feat he achieved at a
relatively young age however despite
Harry's illustrious track record he did
get an awful lot of help from the people
around him he also just had a lot of
plain old good luck for these reasons he
isn't higher on the list porpentina or
Tina Goldstein was a gift to Aura the
former investigator for the magical
Congress of the United States of America
makusa she was dedicated to her job and
showed remarkable bravery during her
time as an aura displaying immense skill
in dueling and non-verbal Magic
however Tina's passion for justice
occasionally led her to take risks that
got her into trouble despite some
setbacks and challenges in her careers
in Aura Tina remained a Fierce and
determined fighter she worked tirelessly
to protect the Wizarding Community as
far as magical abilities are concerned
Tina had the full arsenal she was first
in charms Transfiguration divination
defense against the dark arts Apparition
and more she even held her own
momentarily in a jewel against Gaelic
Grindelwald though I'm not sure
Grindelwald was exercising much of his
power Percival Graves was an American
wizard who had a distinguished career as
an aura eventually becoming the director
of magical security and the head of the
Department of magical law enforcement at
the magical Congress of the United
States of America he was a member of the
influential Wizarding Graves family and
he followed in the footsteps of his
ancestor gondolfus Graves who was one of
the original 12 auras of makusa
as an aura Percival Graves possessed a
formidable skill set that made him a
highly effective and respected member of
the magical law enforcement Community he
demonstrated exceptional knowledge and
expertise in enforcing magical law
upholding Justice and protecting The
Wizarding World from Dark Forces he was
well known for his astute observation
skills strategic thinking and his
ability to analyze complex situations
however as powerful as Graves was he was
no match for the dark wizard Gaelic
Grindelwald who successfully
impersonated him in the Fantastic Beasts
film it's unknown whether Grindelwald
killed or simply imprisoned Graves
Theseus Commander was an English Wizard
and Aura of the British Ministry of
magic he was the son of Mr and Mrs
commander and the older brother of famed
magic zoologist newt's Commander Theseus
gained recognition as a war hero after
his involvement in the first world war
and was later promoted to the head of
the British or office as an aura Theseus
Commander possessed a wide range of
skills that made him an exceptional law
enforcement wizard he had extensive
knowledge of magical law and regulations
which made him a valuable asset in
upholding Justice and maintaining order
in The Wizarding World however it was
theseus's Proficiency in combat
defensive magic that played a key role
in his successful career as an aura his
experiences during the first world war
further enhanced his courage and
resilience as he played a vital role in
the battle against skelic Grindelwald
and the global Wizarding war that
followed Gawain rubad was a British
wizard who served as an aura for the
British Ministry of magic during the
second Wizarding War he later became
head of the British or office succeeding
Rufus grimga who became the minister for
magic as an aura Gawain rabards proved
to be a fierce fighter against the dark
arts battling against Lord Voldemort and
his followers during the second
Wizarding War even during the Ministries
losing battle against them
though the ministry fell Gawain was able
to survive later returning to his role
as head of the aura office after
Voldemort had been defeated the fact
that Gawain was put in charge of the
aura office during such a volatile time
suggested he was a particularly gifted
leader and likely a very powerful wizard
in his own right her feisty score was
one of the earliest auras and served as
Minister for Magic from 1752 to 1770.
Gore's successful tenure as the minister
for magic attests to his many qualities
that made him an excellent Aura and
leader he was a skilled strategist who
was able to put down revolts by magical
beings despite their increased Threat
Level during the goblin rebellions in
the mid-18th century he also officiated
the infamous broom race from Aberdeen to
Rome showcasing his ability to handle
high pressure situations and uphold the
Dignity of The Wizarding Community Gore
was also responsible for undertaking
their renovation and reinforcement of
Azkaban prison Gore's quick thinking and
Innovative approach to problem solving
set him apart as one of the best auras
of his time Kingsley shackle bolt was a
British purebred wizard Order of the
Phoenix member powerful Aura and later
Minister for magic as a high-ranking
aura Kingsley displayed a very powerful
and balanced arsenal of magical
capabilities
shacklebolt's fellow order members held
him in high regard and even Lord
Voldemort himself considered Kingsley to
be a powerful wizard if that isn't an
indicator of his level of power then I
don't know what is shacklebolt exhibited
natural cunning outstanding dueling
ability full defense against the dark
arts proficiency charms Mastery
Transfiguration Mastery potions Mastery
apology Mastery Apparition Mastery
flying Mastery and more he truly was a
master of all and was able to
comfortably hold the Zone against at
least two Death Eaters at once in fact
during the battle of the seven Potters
shackle bolt was by five Death Eaters
and even though he was primarily focused
on protecting Hermione shacklebolt was
able to stun two of them and Escape as
far as auras come Kingsley is one of the
best Rufus Grim girl of the British pure
blood wizard veteran Aura and later
Minister for magic scrimger spent most
of his life as an aura defeating dark
witches and wizards for years and it was
through years and years of experience
that scrimga came to achieve his level
of magical power scrimka was in
Dumbledore's words a man of action and
was far more decisive than his
predecessor Cornelius fudge before
becoming Minister for magic Rufus was
the head of auras this title alone
speaks to his ability to handle himself
his level of expertise and his inherent
magical capability as head of a division
that focuses on capturing dark Wizards
we can only assume that his magical
proficiency was truly A step above those
Underneath Him in perhaps the most
relevant Testament to scrim capabilities
he was able to put up a valiant effort
against the Dark Lord Voldemort one of
the most powerful Wizards to have ever
lived though scrimke was defeated giving
someone as powerful as Voldemort a fight
is an extremely notable accomplishment
in and of itself last but certainly not
least we have Alistair Mad Eye Modi
Moody was a Scottish pure blood Wizard
and is considered by many to be the most
famous Aura of all time he was an order
of the Phoenix member dark wizard
Catcher And Warrior Moody served with
great distinction during the first
Wizarding War losing an eye leg and nose
in battle against evildoers Moody is
personally responsible for a large
number of the witches and wizards in
Azkaban and this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
Community Alistair Moody was hired as
defense against the dark arts Professor
by Dumbledore in 1994 but before
starting his new posting was ambushed in
his home by Barty Crouch Jr and Peter
Pettigrew though he fought Valiant the
surprising nature of the attack led to
his eventual downfall and he was trapped
inside of his very own magical trunk it
is my personal opinion that Barty Crouch
Jr is one of the most powerful Death
Eaters of all time and even though we
don't see him exercising his magical
capabilities too much I think that he
had a lot more in him than what we were
shown for this reason it makes sense
that along with Pettigrew Crouch Jr was
able to capture the revered Aleister
moody moody was incredibly brave but
also extremely powerful particularly in
his prime many feel as though his
abilities may have peaked during the
first Wizarding war and that he had
dropped down a peg by the time the
second Wizarding war came around the
result of years of hard battling similar
to Shackle bolts Moody was regarded as
one of the most powerful members of the
Order of the Phoenix by Lord Voldemort
himself for this reason Voldemort
suspected that Moody was likely the
wizard protecting Harry during the
battle of the seven potters and was
initially targeted by the mort for this
reason it was only after Moody Was
Defeated that Voldemort pursued
shacklebolt which tells me that
Voldemort likely felt that Moody was the
more powerful of the two Moody's magical
Arsenal was not limited in any way and
he had no holes in his armor he was a
master of dark arts defense against the
dark arts dueling charms Transfiguration
potions herbology Apparition flying
non-verbal magic and even occlimency for
all of the reasons listed above I feel
that he was the most powerful Aura of
all time and that's it for today's video
and through this comprehensive
exploration of the power and prowess of
every Aura in The Wizarding World we
have delved deep into the magical
abilities skills and achievements of
these Brave Defenders Of The Wizarding
Community from the legendary auras who
fought in the first Wizarding War to the
modern day heroes who battled against
the Resurgence of dark Forces no Aura
has been forgotten ranking auras can be
a daunting task as each individual
brings their own strengths and
weaknesses to the table some possess
exceptional spell casting abilities
While others shine in strategic thinking
and Leadership there are those who excel
in combat and dueling and others who
specialize in the study and containment
of magical creatures the diversity of
skills amongst auras makes it
challenging to definitively determine
who is the most powerful so in that
respect I've just tried my best
would you rank these powerful witches
and wizards let me know down in the
comment section below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live